yeah welcome to this video for around
seven of tata steel 2013 and its own
round seven meaning we almost yo at
halftime so to say we have got 13 rounds
total so let's see what happened today
I'll start with the game Lego against
Carlton and if you've got the suspicion
that this is probably not the most
exciting game and therefore i start with
it then you're right we have from the
dreaded berlin defense against the ROI
and silicone went for the rookie one
line which i'm already yeah called very
very boring in some previous round and
this game is no exception um after
couple of moves yeah we have this
redeployment black wants to play d5 and
this is a wise idea to prevent d 75 but
still um if you look at this this Bishop
gets traded off white doesn't want to
play air for this would only weaken his
position so something like this is some
simply obstructing the bishop and it's a
really wrong way to try to avoid some
difficult raided nine f6 and queen
default so white has got some space
advantage but of course black it's very
solid and you can already anticipate the
exchanges down the e-file
yeah 94 it's not really the kind of move
that tests black too much but yeah it's
simply a very dull position Carlton just
when Drew key aide and check we have
this further exchanges yeah here wyd
decided to not take off our rooks and
we'd use them I put all tension out of
the position or tension there is I mean
he played rookie d1 this is probably a
good idea to have at least some flame
and okay but really there is not much
happening we see that Nico was spending
lots of time where Carlson was really
playing almost almost instantly and this
continues throughout the game you've got
some some more exchanges and here it's
really over with all kinds of tries for
white on his own yeah you get to this
Bishop end game and here white only has
a very slight symbolic advantage with
this poem that you can attack and I
think at least for me and surprisingly a
likkle one place on until really flip
very very long time and I mean I don't
really see how black should lose it just
stays on d7 protect those those two
pawns okay they're on light squares that
it's not very attractive but how do you
ever make any progress white can almost
never play a 4 and opening the King side
is also not not easy and it also
wouldn't let anything yeah well whatever
we get
coming off more moves the egg white
moves the King to to the Kings side and
all the way back it's a it's simply
nothing happening and let go spend time
really a lots of time okay he's very
good at exploiting small advantages this
is of course a well known fact but there
is certainly nothing the clock terms of
course a bit weird a mismanaged ignore
that but it's here that Carlton heads up
close to two hours on the clock at the
end is simply a moved instantly and
frankly speaking it as I mean I don't
know how to how to lose this it's like
very difficult to see unless you drop
dead you you won't lose this game so not
much happening um simply this line is
just too tame yeah some time came some
players really seem to UM yeah play it
very safe against Carlton one and it's
hard to win this way all so you don't
lose so much but how how would you ever
try to win okay not much happening
unfortunately min this game so on what
else was that we got the Dutch duel
allow me again scary and let me actually
place a one of my openings which I
sometimes play this Red Team you should
reform yeah in the same position lamb
you played queen bee three which is some
the safe move I actually play Bishop g2
enter offer this pawn which is much
sharper and a bit more interesting
probably queen bee three a good odds
with Quincy seven which covers this
problem with a little tactic
why would try to grab here he needs to
remember that the c1 is actually hanging
and after not c3 something like this
like is perfectly fine yeah in fact that
we have got a six and like some put up a
very solid term position in the center
yeah 92 is on a relatively good try to
get at least a little bit of something
the idea is to play e-form and this is
what happened some exchanges yeah auntie
em in this kind of position on white
enjoys really very very slight advantage
the night is some on a good squared we
see that the black doesn't really want
to get get this bishop traded so he
retreated and this is the consequence
why it gets to add form going to be six
exchange and here white has ideas with
entering on d6 you played bishop t6 they
also cut down think of night to d6 but
there's this little problem and those
two pieces are hanging and then this
will cost material so Bishop to g6 and
this led to an invasion on g6 by the
night which looks nice but unfortunately
it's only temporary achievement to see
that black regroups to get rid of the
night and wide exchange the problem ISM
you cannot really support it with the
sea bonus now this one gets lost and
yeah if you retreat the night then black
is fairly quick and pressurizing d4 and
how do you protect it you cannot play
what you want
and so the bishop is on gphone and a
move like f3 is also very very ugly
let's say like this + d 4 is really a
problem so this is where white took on
the eight now played c5 the effector
this is a very correct game but bit dull
then they both play the moves that that
are good in the position but they're
simply only need two unequal an equal
game yeah we have little slide imbalance
now with the deep on against b6 this be
six point is potentially good to this
white can maybe get a passed pawn but
like always has enough counter play with
this deponent in the center a couple of
moves later we see that this pawn is
hanging and white wants to trade it off
and here draw was the grid yeah both
sides them cannot really make any
progress the the logical continuation is
something like this king here check
check back and back to deform and
there's no way for both sides to get
anything going so yeah correct game but
not too exciting for the spectator okay
zoeken off against how I Krishna azucar
love has lost I think two games in a row
against Carlton and ronnian the wrong
before and therefore I guess he
certainly wanted to have a safe game he
played III his pet line here are you he
actually has some it's written a book
last year about this the strategic names
of Indian it's cold and it's certainly
the the best book on the e3 line that
has some been published
and all this in them I don't know
300-something pages okay b6 the the cup
of variation at all this is some
substandard and well known yeah white
redeploys this bishop to be one and
wants to set up this battery against the
h seven witches really a standard set up
in the isolated Queens pawn there are
alternatives but this is one standard
plan like retreats you should to be one
and now goes the light to be forward and
tensor this blockade on d5 and now 95 I
know it's an interesting and interesting
point if black now would play the move
that looks natural in connection with
not before I mean this move then after
Queen d3 white would would get what he
wants this attacking ideas against them
the h-bomb and in fact them like is like
and play this position yeah I'm not
saying he is is losing or something but
this is really giving white what you
wanted but like would play move like age
6 cm I mean HW you need to know to
attend this threat the point actually is
that if white would take on d5 now blank
would take with the Queen and would even
win the game tonight can we treat here
and now has aged six as a possible
attacking target so like be 25 is
something that wide would welcome
instead he played 96 and this is much
stronger it looks a bit weird to play to
be four and then right back but the
situation has changed the night is only
five now and now black simply a texty
form
with the night actually not with the
Queen Queen D forward three answered by
96 but this is the idea black gets
immediate counter play against the
deform and what should why do now it's a
bit a bit of a problem if you return to
cover it then there's at least the
repetition and you actually admit that
you don't have much so I what should why
to lose or cut off plate Queen d3 anyway
but this allowed to simplification and
now black plate the good news look F 2d
eight and in me intermediate move
attacking the bishop if white would take
now and f6 blank just recaptures very
strong attacking both bishops and like
actually has even the better game then
because he will get one of the bishops
and we'll have a good Bishop pay at the
end so why turn leads to we treat this
d3 bishop and now we have some exchanges
now a 7s hanging enter 96 is an idea but
black defense accurately let's be sure
to d5 counter attacking the a to pawn
and here he got it back and only needs
to worry now about be six white has
slide temporarily initiative with the
rook here Adam he simply defended well
and with this maneuver gone to the e5
pawn back yeah like has restored
material equality and yeah white at the
end its left with the beep on a pass be
porn but black has no problems at all
because he's well centralized and
especially the king is involved so we
see that black has no problems at all
white cannot push this pawn so it's
arguable that black
is slightly more comfortable but in the
game local law firm managed to
consolidate land and here just check
just the repetition of move our moves
unfolded with the draw agreement here so
um yea rather solid game I guess Zuko
lock was glad to to have this draw and
Howie Krishna would like also wasn't too
too upset about this all right next
let's check the game who you found
against Cara wanna yeah the Chinese an
ex-world champion women world champion
had won the first game yesterday and now
with the white pieces certainly am
trying to yeah maybe strike again
against one of the most promising young
players kawana okay before as usual and
Kara wanna chooses the calm variation of
the Sicilian should be three you should
see five yeah this is a fairly typical
maneuver nowadays I'm like a text the
night end after the night goes to be
three just drops back to his heaven and
this is not a loss of tempo because the
night is significantly worse position
don't be three compared to deform and
quite often it even wins the tempo
because the night in some lines goes
back to the fourth as it simply is
needed that in some situation then then
black has gained even a move with Bishop
e7 the drawback our firm this maneuver
is that white has the opportunity to
play Queen G for taking the g7 porn and
yeah black doesn't really am have a
convenient way to defend it and a really
convenient way he can play Bishop f6
which is also a viable option
but this always runs into these kind of
ideas amongst other things but this is
one idea so the most popular move this
is what Kara wanna played this is g6
this is also slight drawback we will see
on what I'm talking about right now put
the Queen back it doesn't do much on g4
anymore d6 cancels i know not a 3 first
yeah this is a quite an interesting way
to to use the night but it is a good way
the idea is that white wants to set up
this idea and yam 92 would obstruct
abyss obstruct the bishop and therefore
not a 3 is a good idea it's also on one
point that if black will play b5 I mean
this looks really silly immediately but
just to illustrate the point then
White's ideas that he's got c4 or she's
got c4 and the nitre nicely supports
this SP for that c2 would attack the
spawn immediately and the Sun would be
very good for white so I will be five is
silly as mentioned but then 96 there
should be three and the problem is now
black needs to attend to this so it
plays would be eight the ideas of white
would go Nancy for now which is stupid
thin b5 kicks the light back so just
castles and now we see the problem of
the move g6 black is basically out of
use for moves he can play yes some half
moves like Quincy seven or Bishop d7 or
something but one problem is how how
would you ever get cancelled in this
position if you play a knight to f6 then
let's bishop age six and you cannot
castle and it's very hard to untangle
this so he decided that he
he needs to cancel after all I'll
prepare that let's say and place Knight
f6 and white them yeah instantly took
the chance to play Bishop h6 and now you
cannot cancel on it's not a huge problem
at the moment but it can get a problem
if white would have some more time to
prepare then f4 f5 or f45 the night
would centralize and so on I mean you
cannot stay like this forever so he he
played me five and this intense amongst
others the move Knight g4 probably to
attack the bishop and then get rid of it
and yeah here white I used the
opportunity and she played Bishop g7
group g8 and took on f6 so y term
sacrifice the bishop pair form yeah
destroying blacks castling rights and
setting up slightly an ammonia sir set
up for black like needs a cabin of moves
to get to sort his position and in this
time y term has improved the peace
position the night drops back from a
three two drops backs not the right word
yeah he proves this position from a 323
where it controls d5 in fact from a
structure point of view um yeah black
doesn't have a problem really it's a
fairly standard corn structure from the
night or form other lines like this
rationally cover Kalashnikov variation
what would like a disadvantage compared
to this lines is that these pieces are
ya the wrong way wrong way around if the
rook would be a g8 and the rook on the
eight then yeah there's simply nothing
for white but like it needs to lose time
to get this out in a sorted out
so let's continue a few moves it's all
very very logical I think improving the
pieces and yeah black got the King to g7
and white them reposition this night to
put some pressure on the d6 pawn enter
control d5 yeah probably intending f5 at
some point ok 3 into the 8th Bishop c4
oops no upon see what sorry kwanzaa form
and he liked him took off this this
night fairly standard to get rid of this
bishop he could have done that all the
time but he waited until this pawn
landed on c4 Queen takes yeah in this
position I'm black had a choice he
decided to play him yeah sit and wait
move um also could have played f-fine
which yeah which I like actually not the
most patient person in the world so like
to play those active news if possible
but of course you also weaken yourself a
bit so maybe he didn't like that so much
but I think it certainly playable it's
not completely terrible move yeah well
Bishop d7 trying to improve the bishop
925 big stakes yeah this is some very m
common pawn structure and this is silly
and actually and those Sicilian lines
with d5 white has got a space advantage
and he's got or she in this case got
four against three so four pawns my
white against three were black and
therefore white intends to play for a
passport on the queenside and actually
the
peace positioning you mean with rook a3
is very flexible and white is quick with
before um doesn't look too bad this
positions usually it's favorable for
white to have a couple of pieces
exchanged and this has already happened
here the typical counterplay is actually
f5 and we see in the game let's see what
happens rupee 8i Queen music this is an
interesting decision I actually think
that this move phone is probably even
better as it prevents the beep on
advanced and has got this idea group III
to b6 which would be a very nice
position for the rope um but okay night
Queen to be six is also interesting yeah
black hasn't got much choice yeah and
here we see that this is the candidate
on that white would like to promote in
the long run with be for c5 and c6 left
possible yeah I believe white is some
slightly better in this position and
black needs to get counter play quickly
and this is what he did he went for a
five instantly before and Ephraim
getting a pass on himself take stakes
and we should be too yeah but black hair
needs to be careful here it's not not so
easy um I'm not sure every before and
some tea was so great but it's not so
easy because white has a very
straightforward anthem and ended easy
plan if white would manage to get her
King to e3 and then let's say whoopsie
325 what would have a clear advantage so
black needs to get some can some kind of
counter play really quickly and this is
why I tried h5 they are dealing to play
oops not there Bishop g4 um as we see
the king of two was played I'm this
Bishop g4 what he played
it's actually a big mistake I'm probably
something like this was better
preventing c4 c5 for the moment but this
leads to the mentioned position with
rookie with King III where white should
be better also so now that I think of it
probably for wasn't such a great
decision after all the instant before
maybe some preparation what's better
white is slightly better anyway but this
seems to help I mean have white yeah
okay so we should reform and now I'm
here who you found played the move from
F somehow somehow wrong she played the
move a through an h3 and this is also a
mistake in return so to say if white
would simply play this move here keep
taking nc5 I think yeah like would be in
in almost almost yeah the decisive
decisive trouble and I don't see how you
would would hold this position before
g4s all week got King III coming
Brooksie 36 is an idea I mean this is
sam this is close to being completely
lost the computer actually am gives
white completely winning winning
evaluation and it looks terrible this
simply gave black another pawn weakness
what I think is she played she played 83
and probably overlooked cheese III check
otherwise a tree would have been a good
move also a taking was service was
really simple and I'm probably decisive
after e3 like a manages to get the
activity that that he needs
takes and looking for this is the
important thing that this rook instantly
a taxi for and you cannot really keep
this pawn if white would try to cover it
something like this yeah okay white good
could try to cover this way but then
like would them activate the king and
this is enough to to keep the balance so
we had this exchange check and after
couple of more moves check we're not
much happened check check check a draw
was agreed so yeah big chance here miss
by Wu Yifan she could have gotten the
next big scalp here with capturing on g4
and then c5 and um yeah bit of a shaky
game back i wanna easily could have
could have lost yet if the time is
correct she was down to 30 seconds here
yeah this looks like yeah she was very
very low on time here I mean that time
is not one hundred percent accurate here
but usually close to the truth so maybe
this was the real point that the time
management all right so a draw in this
game the next one that I wanted to show
is kayaking against Aronian so very
important for the standings Aronian has
won two games in a row and certain he
was looking for for more and kayaking is
one win behind Magnus on shared second
place okay the ruler Pez yeah somehow as
mentioned in this tournament there a
lots of e four players and lots of
players 285 so we've got this ruler
ruler pass openings all the time yeah we
have a 4 here
another entire Marshall turonian prefers
this before move yeah all fairly logical
black wins a temple with the night to a
five and now I'm is able to use the C
porn fairly standard moves and now white
goes for deform this son has been played
before I am I just briefly looked it up
but it's not a main line yeah like
captures two times the idea is that if
white would take now on you for let them
could play this this kind of this kind
of way and push the bishop all the way
back to be one this is why white
probably went Bishop to F for Nia first
and maybe recapture later but now
Aronian um played the interesting move
v3 and this some somehow gets right into
some coordination trouble he captured of
course and now Bishop to e6 yeah and now
we see that this is quite annoying here
so white knight I'm gap cannot really
move white also cannot take on deform
and SB 3 is hanging some of this this is
what I'm talking about and what should
white actually play he decided to go
Bishop a to get out of this attack by
the rook but then d3 was played very
interesting role in this very creative
player in the in DC 45 structures and
okay this has a technical idea of why it
takes and which he did um but also
intense maybe two
am I to be form actually securing this
pawn so this is why we have this kind of
transformation and now whoopsie 8 this
is the point getting this night into a
pin on the rook III and 94 yeah very
nice piece of calculation by aronian and
this transforms a position to something
that must be slightly better for black
it's got the tivity effect active night
and this first line that we have now
with d5 leads to math simplifications
okay Queenie r5 so like attack this pawn
and still has got pressure on the c4
white plate the Bishop b5 this is very
sensible you want to get rid of from one
of blacks bishops he took and I think
here white made them made a slight a
slight mistake but the movie played is
very natural Queenie 5 taking attacking
the Queen and I think he probably
somehow miscalculated night xe5 still
seems to be around equal it it's maybe
this moves that he didn't like to get
into this this big pin but it seems that
after what was the move Thank You Wendy
to was smooth just a second gluten need
to check this Queen d2 yeah Queenie to
this seems to be still I'm rod equal
like takes here yeah this is this is
just completely equal these pawns would
probably get exchanged so this was
played but I forgot this line Queen
takes a form this was also i'm also
something you need to care
but here okay too seems to seems to draw
instantly against a six like we'll get
c4 of course so we have a complete trade
of everything yeah this is this led to
trouble Queen takes a fall with the
tempo and in fact there's a funny
technical possibility in this position
which we are about to see in in the next
move and yeah what what should should
white play now this is hanging on
because of three times attacked if white
would cover like this like would just
win the pawn so what he tried is a lie
to deform and if like now would would
take like this then does this move
coming and it gets very embarrassing on
g7 widest instantly winning f6 crew g3
and you have no decent way to defend
this but this move was plate Bishop
takes h3 and this can certainly come as
a shock for the white player I'm not
sure if he if we saw this or if this was
coming as a surprise the idea of course
if white would take then rook e8 the
screen on a form from far away covers
the pawn and black winter decisive
material so black work just won this
pawn quite quite a funny way and he also
has got the bishop against the night
which can be an important advantage
white activates and black simply has a
large advantage now and he managed to to
make a complete winning position out of
this around here black gum has a really
really completely winning position but
it's still not entirely easy
and we will see what happened Roxy 3
Queen a 1 so this pin is annoying cause
at first the rook is saying so check he
gave his check and now move the night
back to protect the rook there wasn't
anything else Bishop g4 this is not the
most exact move but it probably still
wins and the best one actually was work
to h1 check check king must go to g3 not
very convenient but um I'm sorry best
actually wants to attack the night first
I forgot about that like a text the
night and the problem is if it moves
then c 3 is falling so why it's only
move is to attack this bishop in return
with route d3 and now you can check King
g3 and queen to f6 and this was a this
is really completely over now black
threatens Queen to h4 and if white would
take the bishop chairs check this line
winning the rook and completely
completely over so this this would have
won but he relatively quickly played
Bishop g4 it still keeps them a winning
advantage but makes it considerably more
difficult the trick is Queen f4 and
after takes 25 it's an immediate draw
very unfortunate maybe he played Bishop
g4 yeah if you believe the time you
played this relatively quickly and this
can be one of the cases where you have
seen this move a couple of moves earlier
and you think you just reproduce the
line and that you have planned and then
there's this nasty surprise and this can
really
unsettle a player of you will look this
move yeah she gave the check on h1 King
g3 and now h 5 which is strong there
should be two as mentioned allows this
draw with them Queen at five yeah black
am is still clearly better but it's not
so easy played rookie 3 now protecting
the night and here probably black should
just play Bishop you six now the problem
is if you if you would cheat the check
now why just grabs the bishop and if you
are play Bishop b6 which would be my
suggestion then you actually threaten
this pushing the king of here and
continue in the attack and also this
Bishop attacks the c-4 porn it's a very
difficult for y2 to even make a move
here that not instantly losses if for
example white would play something like
94 check there's this simple
continuation and Bishop g5 check is a
big problem yeah this um this Bishop is
six more firm seems to win really maybe
I'm white needs to even to prevent
immediate mates and to play something
like this but of course this just
surrenders the pond and black has two
extra points even with one extra pond if
you only would have the a pond it would
be a very very close to winning with
Bishop against night even night some uh
notoriously bad against them the flank
bones the a a pawn of the H porn yeah
probably should be six was was a winner
what he did Queen a five also didn't
didn't look bad at all but it's now
certain it's now slowly slipping away
from like um he had one chance
still check let's continue your company
moves ya hear what goes for the mate the
mate threat um and here black really
needed to play Queen be a check check
and this I think was was still offering
fair winning chances on white must play
a form the only move and then Queen to
be one and the Queen on v1 of course
covers g6 and this still looks quite
clearly better for me for black so I'm
not quite sure why didn't didn't play
this certainly a roni I was very
disappointed that he still was playing
actually of course he was aware that he
should win but he didn't really managed
to find the decisive moves check he
played Queen here and now after a form
you don't really am have a good way to
prevent the mate he went for the
exchange leg and queen here alright some
it's it's a draw now White's King is too
bad so wyd cannot really play for win he
can lose in some some funny ways of
course if white would play some some
silly move like g3 for example then you
check and Jen chikni can get mated in
this way quite nice but ok g3 is really
a suicide move ok played kings III back
preventing all kinds of yeah those kind
of suicide missions now are not possible
why just secures the king and check this
actually ended in in a perpetual check
check yeah and to draw yeah very
disappointing for Aronian who played
really a good creative game got the
winning position and
then some are butchered it up in here
this way with Bishop g4 this was the
cleanest way with rookie one to win and
he even had some chances later but
somehow somehow missed those yeah this
is nowadays at the moment the difference
between what number three and five on
number six and cards and cows and just
he just wins those games he's got a
technically winning position he
absolutely i can't remember when he last
miscalculated and in such a good
position or or butchered a perm defense
with the miscalculation really am
amazing but those arrows still happened
to to those other players and this is
really a slight difference but they but
it is a difference okay so draw in this
game the next one that i wanted to show
is on aunt against van valley is she
having a good tournament after a long
period of of draught so to say the
scandinavian defense when veiny is
really a playing all kinds of surprised
openings in this went queen a5t 49 f 6
yeah and alan certainly couldn't
couldn't reckon with this opening he
played bishop to d2 which is a very rare
line against the scandinavian normal are
the standard moves like Knight f3 or
Bishop to c4 Bishop b2 is really rare we
see that after couple of moves yeah
cannot take on v2 group v 1 v 7 would be
good for white after a couple of moves
black managed to get the v3 bishop and
now enjoys the two bishops but it's not
so great besides that because the queen
is a bit exposed on b6 okay it's a
Scandinavian view you are used to this
but then other than that black can be
quite satisfied yeah although your
normal white improve the night and now
this night controls the important
squares c5 and 85 yeah black tries to
regroup the Queen get it back into play
and we she plays that night in form yet
here then Valley I think I chose the
wrong plan he took only four which is
probably a ride but now he went for f5
and this I think is um yeah pretty big
mistake and I think I would prefer white
slightly am here anyway but f5 just
reconsidered the position too much it
probably should play some some slow move
like let's say be 60 and trying to give
this Bishop an additional square um and
um white looks a bit more active with
the center can also play maybe reform
preventing c5 but black soulless
relatively solid tee at least doesn't
have any porn weaknesses or direct
weaknesses sum of squares in the game
after this f5 just have a look white
captured and plates afford you see that
'if I've is a supposed for whites pieces
six is also week the direct threat is D
5 D 5 Bishop c5 and this really gets
downhill very quickly of course when
really was some aware of this is not a
bad player he's I reckon he had some who
I'm sorry he had some tactical idea in
mind that that didn't work I'm not quite
sure what it should be because it's
pretty clear from a strategic point of
view that f5 is terrible he certainly
had some concrete idea which didn't work
but I don't know what it was he played
the bishop before now and after 95 why
just threatens to win the set only for
porn and yeah black it really doesn't
have much to to prevent this he actually
would be sure before initiated the
sequence but really add I don't know
what to recommend for black instead of
the smooth you can easily lose in some
the Nets a bishop here d5 push it back
Bishop c5 when the queen is trapped so
an unknown Bishop before at least needs
pretty much by force to the game and he
was gone yeah white just won this pawn
and then I have a look at the clock
times it's a 18 minutes left for when
venient one hour 2400 so this is some a
non-playing in his old style playing a
moves very quickly more like a rapid
game than a classical time control game
he used to do this 25 years ago all the
time when he was what the youngster he
regularly played tournament games in 20
minutes but nowadays he usually takes
more time but in some recent games he
sped up again and
yeah if it's working you don't don't
blunder something then you put lots of
pressure on the opponent yeah okay we
have an endgame here with white just
having an extra pawn and they are pretty
much didn't happen didn't happen so so
much the usual kind of improvement moves
by both sides black tries to stop white
from advancing further and white gains
space on the on the Kings side yet here
and then really made a tactical mistake
but I think in the long run it's
probably lost anyway he played rook to
have eight and this allowed d5 it's a
neat trick that year maybe wanted to set
up like just took here the ideas if I
would take on f8 now Chen Bishop c5
check on the King we inspect the rook
and black is even better but white
hazardous intermediate check and this
wins instantly now if black plays King
back to age seven then there's GG 6
check and check here's just a clean
piece and a complete went out so so
after rookie 6am went very resigned yeah
pretty clear win for for fishing and
yeah he's now joint cards and internal
heat with plus three it's good to see
him back in normal normal shape winning
game sir quickly alright so i think i'm
only did I have all the games on let's
say it it and I forgot one they are
still one how against my camera okay one
how deform and nakamura playing them so
codes trying out set up Quincy to buy
one now which is a solid way to in cow
to this securing the sea porn the thing
is if white would play the
normal-looking move Knight c3 then black
amongst others would have the choice to
play the very sharp notable variation
was d takes e4 actually intending to
keep the spawn if possible very sharp
stuff Quincy to just protect see find
some much more solid yeah Nakamura I
decided to take and initiate queenside
play with b5 we have fun a fairly
standard kind of opening position but
now this this move um I didn't look up
the theory here must submit but it's
very uncommon for white to to take on b5
so Ollie usually white tries to get
developed first like Bishop to d3 or
Bishop to e2 because he wants to take on
b5 in a position where black is actually
forced to take with the a porn so on one
ideas let's say just from a structured
point of view it's probably not this
exact position something like this that
after this exchange at the end I keep
Miss clicking the b5 porn is somewhat
isolated and this weaker than the b2
porn as White's pieces are closer to and
taking this pawn than blacks out to be
two and this might be m good for a
slight advantage if if it materializes
in the game he took on b5 instantly and
now now come where I took the chance to
recapture with the C porn and this
actually freeze this Bishop immediately
putting pressure on e4 and allows the
PlayBook b8 with the tempo and I think
I'm ya hear black already has gotten and
rather comfortable position he can get
out his pieces quickly and even win time
play this rook c8 with the tempo as
mentioned queen imani I wanted to
additionally
check the football this is why didn't go
to 2b 3b three is also a possible place
for the night age six and now white
played Bishop e3 not sure that I like
this so much but I didn't really find
something better the issue is this one
and black will get the bishop Pam and
not only this he now played castles
actually I think why should consider
this move simply because now white can
use this Bishop on d3 for something at
least yeah for for trading before
trading against blacks bishop in the
game he didn't play me five he played
castles and now black plate d 5 which is
really strong this simply blockades
those two pawns and keeps White's bishop
we're on a very bad spot on d3 yeah
black certainly has a slight advantage
here it's at least much easier to play
95 yeah yeah black I'm played in Bishop
a8 King edge 1 and in this position
learn a camera i decided to play for and
for tactical um yeah technical
transformation he had an alternative he
played am Bishop takes a five but in
fact he could also just take and play
Knight f6 and this sir is simple but
very strong um how does white protect
the spawn cannot play wiki one with some
bishop is on before he would play me
five then there are some this
intermediate move
and black is just clearly better what is
this piece doing who also the the center
is very vulnerable and what should why
do this pawn is hanging and you cannot
see how too proud to protect it I think
this is even stronger than the game and
in the game now come we're also had an
advantage he took and now play an f5 so
I'm a direct technical solution using
the fact that those pieces are somewhat
yeah placed a lil unlucky way why would
take this before winning a piece you
know what I decided to take on a 6 end
after this sacrifice Lee exchange think
this is a really good good defensive
tribe take stakes group d 8 okay one so
white has got a pawn for the exchange
and still hopes to liquidate the b5 porn
which would get him a much nearer to
draw so if you will be able to get to
get rid of the be pawns and exchange
down a bit so that you have from just a
bishop pendulum bishop on all night and
born and you can probably draw this
Knight b6 yeah and like obviously
intends to attack the beep on ya hear
white um probably should them play a
prophylactic move like h3 protecting the
back rang so that you have a flat square
own age to after this move you still
have Bishop to c6 and you can have on I
mean black is better but in exchange is
an exchange even for born but white can
fight and try to draw this game what he
played okay five you can treat as a
little technical puzzle what does black
play now boom and the default bone is
just gone yeah he'd simply blunted to
the background mate and down just over
on how had 40 minutes left so this is
really a bad mistake for playoff his
level yeah white is now instantly lost
he is no way to save himself the bishop
is also hanging so it's a tempo gain and
now like guess God even the play against
the beep on yeah just a couple of moves
later check it got traded down and here
this is relatively easy win as the night
and rook will it take on the on the King
side and likes king also gets activated
the fairly easy win and in fact them it
did and ended rather rather quickly with
this attack on g2 um yeah quite resigned
yea rather bad game by wrong how he was
in trouble pretty quickly and then
London to this group takes d4 shot
winning him the porn for black end
immediately the game yeah okay around
with them some not so eventful drawers
but still two wins by Arnold enter
Nakamura like I'm were also now on plus
two he didn't play the most spectacular
tournament but he did what he what he he
won what he was unable to do he won
against when he found with black and now
this game of flag so he's on plus two
and not far away from the tournament
lead yeah thanks for watching this video
spin um almost one hour again and I
probably be back tomorrow but I'm not
one hundred percent sure as I need to
play myself
sure how long this will take but most
likely i do a video tomorrow somewhat
later I was lacking yeah till then why